notre panel politique mais non daniel
bord de l'eau à montréal michel c'est
ogier à montréal également tasha
kheiriddin à toronto bonsoir messieurs
dames
bonsoir à daniel bord de l'eau vous êtes
spéciales et si on peut le dire de
l'aviation de toutes ces questions je
vous pose la première question est ce
que vraiment le gouvernement québécois
avait le choix que de signer un très
gros chèque de 1,3 milliard pour tenter
de donner un nouveau souffle à 6 séries
ces nouveaux appareils
non je pense qu'elle veut pas le choix
parce que les alternatives aurait été
encore pire que de signer un gros chèque
bombardier n'est pas en faillite parce
que bombardier a encore des ressources
et des filiales sont rentables mais à
défaut de ce gros chèque
il y aurait sans doute fallu vendre des
morceaux qui sont précieux comme
peut-être les avions d'affaires ou
vendre la totalité du transport
ferroviaire
et ça ça aurait handicapés bombardier à
long terme beaucoup plus que d'avoir une
dette si on veut un endroit du
gouvernement avant de passer la parole à
vos camarades daniel une autre question
là dessus est ce que d'après vous les
retards de la cseries son duo à
l'extrême difficulté de ce marché à deux
gros jets à boeing et airbus qui ne
laisse pas de place à bombardier dans
les avions de 110 130 places le nouvel
appareil cseries mais est ce qu'il ya un
espoir
ça c'est une très bonne question en fait
moi je mon point de vue personnel là
dessus c'est que c'est sans doute une
question de prix sur monsieur alain
bellemare est pas tout à fait d'accord
avec moi mais habituellement quand vous
baisser le prix d'un objet ou d'un
produit vous augmentez vos ventes
et là la concurrence d'airbus et de
boeing fait que ces deux grands géants
on va faire des escomptes de 40 à 55 % à
leurs clients et ce qui fait que leur
avion comme l'airbus a320 seront
probablement au même prix ou moins cher
que le cs300 de bombardier alors
évidemment comme le cs300 et un petit
peu plus
si il devrait être moins cher que l'a320
mais avec 5 milliard et demi de dette
il faut que bombardier il fait des
bombardiers la paye et ils pouvaient pas
baissé leurs prix tant que ça là
aujourd'hui avec la radiation d'actifs
qui a été fait ça va être plus facile
d'ajuster le prix d'achat le
gouvernement fédéral en 2008 avait aidé
bombardier pour la cseries pourtant pour
pour lancer ce programme là mais on
s'aperçoit depuis que vraiment c'est
l'image que j'ai les deux gros géant
voit une mouche voler puis veulent la
tuile
c'est dur on en même temps que tout le
monde est une industrie aéronautique
aider son industrie aéronautique
et c'est vrai que les autres pays le
font mais on sait que c'est pas
seulement à cause de la compétition les
avions sont en retard et coûteux
bombardier a plein de problèmes c'est
pas juste dans l'hérault nautique ici à
toronto
la commission de transport de toronto
poursuit bombardier parce qu'ils sont
pas livrés à temps 23 très mou et on
attend 60 très moyen on a juste dit sa
dette
ils ont des problèmes de livraison des
problèmes de manufacture et ces choses
là ne sont pas résolues en simplement
leur livrant un milieu 1.3 milliard de
dollars de l'argent des contribuables ya
aucune responsabilité vraiment qui est
la danse et ses faux de que ce que m
péladeau a dit qu'il faudrait investir
dans l'art est dans mon gardien il
faudrait revoir le fait que le
gouvernement continuellement donne de
l'argent aux compagnies comme bombardier
hockey dont vous remettez ça vous en
question le michel l'aide à bombardier
on a l'impression que c'était ça ou la
cseries allait mourir ou d'autres pas il
faut voir ce que bombardier dans
l'économie du québec vous savez quand
quand des grosses banques avaient des
problèmes au début de la crise de 2008
aux états unis où nous aider en anglais
too big to fail alex à l'échelle du
québec c'est bombardier qui est too big
to fail c'est trop gros pour qu'on est
on les laisse tomber on n'avait pas
vraiment le choix
ça pose un certain nombre de questions
les marchés n'aiment pas beaucoup
l'action de bombardier l est
dollars quelque chose c'est donc une
preuve que beaucoup de gens trouvent
qu'il ya un problème chez bombardier
il ya aussi brave et que la caisse de
dépôt ne veulent pas investir davantage
dans un bombardier la caisse créée très
attention à la gouvernance des sociétés
ça c'est un signe que ça ne va pas très
bien vous savez il faut pas oublier avec
les actions multivotantes la famille
beaudoin bombardier autour d'un bâtiment
il devait pour cela des actions ayant 50
quelques pour cent des actions vos
attentes
ça fait pas nécessairement une bonne
gouvernance quand on a créé une nouvelle
compagnie conte à la tête de laquelle on
nomme daniel johnson qui était déjà sur
le conseil de bombardier
j'ai rien contre monsieur johnson mais
c'est la vieille dame qui va encore être
là alors tout les problèmes de
gouvernance à s'accumulent c'est un
moment donné mais daniel et h à la
tuerie est ce qu'un des problèmes de
fond justement michel viens de le dire
c'est cette propriété ce pouvoir de
contrôle de la famille vaudrait
bombardier sur l'entreprise il ya
beaucoup d'investisseurs et c'est
peut-être ce que qu'on doit remettre en
question et on remet en question la
question justement c'est une compagnie
familiale une compagnie est justement
qui est contrôlé par la famille et les
décisions qui ont été prises par la
famille ont nui à la cua la
compétitivité de cet avion du fait que
comme jadis était en retard les les
des commandes et le fait qu' on a
entrepris cette vision au tout début
écoute on sait que le marché pour ces
avions là n'est pas énorme qu'il ya
beaucoup de concurrence déjà mais se
sont lancé là dedans avec l'appui des
gouvernements qui sont effectivement ils
ont beaucoup d'amis dans les
gouvernements ont c'est ça oui mais je
répète tasha puis je veux entendre
daniel là dessus bord de l'eau je répète
à chaque boeing étaient des à coups de
milliards aussi par les américains
airbus également c'est dans cette
industrie là c'est l'un des plus doués
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut se
lancer là dedans oui à quinze mille
employés au québec on sait ça mais en
même temps c'est ils sont là parce que à
fur et à mesure pendant tous les années
le gouvernement a fait le choix de
donner de l'argent des contribuables à
cette compagnie qui est en mains privées
effectivement daniel là dessus sur la
propriété d'un éleveur de l'eau sur la
propriété ou en fait le pouvoir
compagnie publique dont le sait la
famille détient encore le pouvoir oui
mais là en fait on critique bombardier
la famille beaudoin
parce que ça va mal mais ça allait bien
on critiquerai pas mal moins et je vous
donne des exemples alimentation couche
tard il ya également un contrôle
familial des fondateurs qui est très
fort quebecor cj jeanjean pas cela mais
ce sont des compagnies qui sont pas en
difficulté comme bombardier est alors
dans l'ombre reproche à la famille
beaudoin d'avoir pris les mauvaises
décisions
ça c'est facile à dire aujourd'hui
également parce que en 2008 quand le
projet a été lancé le projet de cseries
c'était pas évident il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de voix pour dire c'est une
mauvaise stratégie
si au cours des années s'est avéré que
c'était beaucoup plus difficile que
prévu alors aujourd'hui on peut dire bon
l'avion le cs300 et rossi aurait mieux
valu faire 1 150 places
on a fait des mauvais choix en
s'attaquant à airbus et boeing on
n'aurait jamais dû s'attaquer à ces deux
géants là qui font plusieurs fois la
taille de bombardier mais à l'époque en
ça semblait une bonne stratégie
et là on est rendu aujourd'hui là est le
problème c'est ça c'est que les retards
sont telles que par exemple le fameux
moteur qui prend beaucoup moins de sens
et qui est beaucoup plus silencieux que
pratt & whitney a développé pour
bombardier maintenant moins bien merci
s'en servent alors la situation et puis
celle de 2008 et ses essais ses cendres
des problèmes de gouvernance d'une
compagnie familiale c'est que des fois
on dit mais c'est notre bébé on y tient
tellement que on prend pas des décisions
d'affaires qui sont aussi avisé qu'on
l'ait compris la chute des années depuis
les années avant 2008 que les
gouvernements différents paliers de
gouvernement donnait de l'assistance à
bombardier pour divers projets c'est pas
la première fois alors c'est là il faut
se poser la question ces problèmes
continuels là et oui ça rapporte
directement il ya eu des succès quand
même la tâche il ya eu des super six un
chien border donne l'argent la halle
industrielle automobile également de
l'argent a beaucoup donné ces dames de
la bombardier oui on a perdu beaucoup
exactement le contribuable et je vous
pose la question a terminé est-ce que
c'est quand même pas un beau rêve je
vous allez me trouver romantique
peut-être bourret et fabriquer un nouvel
appareil ccbbo il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire lada de dire au canada
au québec on va fabriquer un appareil
puis on va les battre sur leur terrain
des super géant hyper subventionné eux
aussi qu'on va décoller pour va se
trouver une niche de marché s'attend à
une bataille très dure et il faut les
livres y est ça vous fûtes et très fermé
le cseries l'appareil est parfait y est
excellent le problème c'est vraiment
d'arriver à le vendre yang grenon et ça
c'est pas une bataille qui va se gagner
du jour l'entente à cheval les gens
attendre 24 heures pour une place à
l'hôpital je pense pas qu'il rêve de
avions cseries avec leur argent je
m'excuse je vous dirais pas que c'est un
beau rêve des boues risque là s'est
rendu à un risque et c'est le problème
de cette transaction là c'est que le
gouvernement du québec a créé une
compagnie à part prend tous les risques
de la cseries et bombardier
reste de la compagnie bon il y aura dit
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui le reste
de la compagnie est pas touché par ça
alors là on a privatisé en or on n'a pas
publié
on a rendu les risques public oui mais
attendez les actionnaires ont quand même
vu le prix de l'action coupé de moitié
depuis le début de l'été est bien quand
même une part du risque qui supportent
je crois que je n'ai pas pu faire de
partager ma vision tabouret chasse sur
se renouvelle aquarelliste et magique et
non non non mais on verra si si jamais
bombardier arrive à vendre et à vendre
ça décolle on sait ce dont je parle dans
deux ans peut-être une année n'y a en a
qui la fabrication jugon secondes chacun
la vraie question c'est jusqu'où on va
aller pour que ça marche parce que man
il faut pas tirer une ligne aussi michel
du second
le problème il est là c'est que la ligue
il ya des erreurs bombardier qui ont été
mis dehors de la compagnie parce qu'il
voulait tirer la ligne la famille d'ilan
c'est notre bébé alors c'est ça qui est
du fait que c'est un gros risque
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement du
québec trois noms de shb ans et plus
seulement que la famille qui décide mais
je pense que il fallait prendre ce
risque là et il ya une possibilité qu'on
arrive à lancer une nouvelle industrie
qui va être très rentable mais faut se
donner probablement cinq à dix ans tâche
aux réquisitions
quelle est la ligne se tire ici au moins
et pas qu'ils m'ont à ottawa et dans un
an ou quoi vous demander plus d'argent
mais c'est trudeau voir daniel bord de
l'eau monsieur j tasha kheiriddin merci
beaucoup
très intéressante et on va suivre ça
parce qu'on est tous impliqués tous ceux
qui paient de l'impôt sont impliqués
dans ce dossier là depuis 2008 s'élève à
face à lui une mission m orban